in 2019 millions of indians watched on
as their nation launched its most
ambitious lunar mission to date
over 80 million dollars had been spent
and the nation's pride was on display
and on the line
narendra modi india's prime minister
watched from mission control as the
lunar lander made its final
heart-stopping descent
then communication was lost
the lander had crashed into the lunar
surface
the encouragement and solidarity
of prime minister modi despite the
failure this mission signaled a new
direction for india's space agency the
isro
through the 90s it had created arguably
the world's most cost effective space
program
with nasa it was about pushing the
boundaries of innovation sending
hardware to areas in the solar system or
in the universe that weren't sent before
within india it was about setting up
infrastructure that could support the
country
over the last decade india has ripped up
its old rule book and launched missions
to mars and the moon
the earlier ambition of helping its
people is now extending to leading the
world
[Music]
our current prime minister mr modi he
does see space as a strategic sector
historically india has not competed with
the mega budgets and ambitions of the
great space fairing nations but that's
changed india now wants to take its next
giant leap into space
india's space story stands apart from
the space pioneering nations
in july 1980 over two decades after
sputnik india launched its rohini
satellite
making them the newest member of an
exclusive club
but the indian space research
organization was trying to do things
differently
unlike nasa or the soviet space program
which aimed to explore space for grand
national and scientific ambitions the
isro was tasked with creating an
indigenous space program solely to allow
india to access the practical advantages
of space india has always maintained
that india wants space science to be
developed for betterment of its people
if you look at it for telecommunications
for electronics india has used base
technology for all of that i would say
the first 20 odd years the focus was on
technology independence how do you build
your own satellites your own earth
stations how do you launch your own
satellites which means you have to build
rockets
by 1994 india had its own liquid stages
rocket the polar satellite launch
vehicle or pslv
early 2000s to late 2010s is when pslv
started becoming the workhorse for the
world people could come here to be able
to launch their satellites for a much
more
cost effective manner and without
compromising on quality that changing of
building hardware only for the country
to then providing these services
globally i think started the beginning
of this century and pslv was a very
critical cog in that
from 1994 to 2017 the rocket launched 48
indian satellites and 209 satellites
from customers abroad
the isro had carved out its own place in
the space sector it was the reliable and
cost efficient way to put a satellite
into orbit
launch costs are measured by how much
you pay to get one kilogram into orbit
in the mid 90s india's pslv rocket was
the cheapest way to get hardware into
space
it cost around 8 500 per kilogram
that compares to nasa's atlas 2 rocket
which cost around 18
700 per kilogram
fast forward to now
and spacex will get you into low orbit
for a fraction of that cost isro has
already acknowledged that the
technologies that are being developed by
elon musk could be a trait to their
business india's competition is rising
they're billionaires entering into the
field for india to maintain that
dominant position the country needs to
step up further
and that step up for india could be its
new small satellite launch vehicle it
will have a payload of 500 kilograms and
deliver multiple satellites in one
mission
but this new rocket may not be enough
the isro is also developing a reusable
rocket like spacex's but the timeline on
that is less clear
in the meantime india signaled its
intent to fundamentally reset its space
program
we focused on technology independence
which was essential for the last several
decades now we need to look outwards and
look far
sushmita mohanty has over two decades
experience in the space industry and
co-founded india's first private space
startup earth to orbit in 2009 she now
runs a space think tank we were sort of
at the crossroads and india started
thinking what next you know we can build
our own stuff we can launch our own
satellites we
use our satellites for a variety of
applications
so i think planetary exploration was
sort of the natural next step if you ask
me
sushmita's think tank spaceport sarabhai
aims to help private companies engage
with the isro as well as promote india
space technology we would like to give
india an international voice especially
when it comes to space law and policy as
it relates to the space environment
space resource mining
in orbit repair and and
the kind of low earth economy that's
starting to emerge
we would also like to provide guidance
to the government on policy matters
using solid research and stakeholder
feedback
[Music]
india's shift from practical space
program to exploration hinges on the
belief that private companies and
private money will take over
india just doesn't have the budget to
spend on these things and private
investment can really come in handy
the current government has always
maintained that there's no
reason for the government to be in
business
and when you look at space as a business
uh like we have seen in the us or in
europe uh the moment you look at space
as a business and not just as a
strategic asset that's when you
encourage private companies to pump in
more money it's not really new for
private companies to invest in indian
space technology
some of the private suppliers have
already supplied to isro but not a
government is opening up we are seeing
uh
private uh satellite players private
launch players so that's something new
and fresh which is being welcomed by
every party
one of those new players is pixel
based in bangalore since 2019 they make
satellite hardware and software
we fit in the new mould of companies
that are operating independently without
having to depend on government support
but work hand in hand to make sure that
whatever heritage that the country has
had cannot be taken to global stages as
well
we're building a constellation of the
world's first hyperspectral imaging
satellites that will provide a much more
detailed view of our planet than has
been possible the constellation will be
global and it will provide data on a
daily basis as well
on the software side of things we take
this data and we build the tools that
will enable extraction of insights such
as yield prediction soil health how's
the pollution happening
pixel is part of a new crop of startups
vying for isro contracts
historically it's been very difficult
for smaller companies to win big state
deals but that's changing isro has done
all that is needed in terms of
indigenous capability now it's the
responsibility of the private sector to
take those up whether it's communication
not observation gps and whatnot and
build on top of that that leaves space
agencies to do cutting edge work that
only governments are willing to spend a
private company can never spend billions
of dollars on something that is only for
purely research and scientific
perspective
this shift in indian space policy is
being driven by prime minister modi
himself he's encouraged india's space
ambitions to be a source of national
i'm
pride
exponential
innovation guy he does see space as a
strategic sector
both from an economy point of view and a
geopolitical uh tool he wants to the
country to sort of progress towards a
five trillion dollar economy so space
can play a very big role both in terms
of products and services as a politician
he knows how space can strategically
help when it comes to war deterrence
space can play a role there and also a
role in diplomacy so i think he he uses
both sides of
both facets of space
but while the government is drumming up
support critics point out the
contradiction that upwards of 360
million indians live in poverty
india is a developing country that runs
a fiscal deficit that runs a budget
deficit
so the amount of money you put into the
space budget is going to be always under
scrutiny for a country that doesn't have
enough toilets for its own people do you
really want to spend money on space
technology the government does have a
tough time at times to convince people
why space technology is needed but at
the same time there are some big
advocates for it
i don't think it's an either our
situation it's that if we spend on space
doesn't mean we're not spending anything
on making other things better
i'll just take a an example schools in
india are spread apart some of them
don't have connectivity to fiber optics
they don't have connectivity to any kind
of internet when india launched its
indigenous communication satellite a lot
of these schools were able to come
online and be connected with what the
other regions of the country were doing
just from the fact that there were a few
communication satellites that were sent
up that enabled that connectivity
because getting the other infrastructure
from a wire perspective was simply not
possible
india's spending needs to be put in
perspective
the us remains the undisputed big
spender accounting for 58
of the world space budget with
47.7 billion dollars spent in 2020
china which has significantly increased
its spending takes second with 8.9
billion dollars
in 2020 india spent just over 2 billion
what the isro and india's space sector
is most proud of is what they've
achieved with so little
if you look at the budget for india
space missions to the moon and to mars
you'll realize that they actually cost a
fraction of what it cost to make a
hollywood movie on space
[Music]
india's first mars mission cost less
than the film the martian
india got its satellite to the red
planet for 74 million dollars 20 million
dollars less than the budget for the
film
then when you compare their mission to
other nations the contrast is even
starker
nasa's mars satellite maven cost 651
million dollars that's more than eight
times the cost of the indian mission
but being frugal may not be sustainable
or desirable
i think budget constraints can be a good
thing but it can also be a limiting
factor
so if you have budget constraints it
invariably uh you know helps you
do things uh using methods of frugal
engineering but that's not always good
when you look at the market and the
economy in the sense if i want to go and
compete internationally i'm a company in
bangalore i would want the kind of
capital that a company in california has
to be able to compete internationally so
i think we we should not stop at frugal
engineering
[Music]
india is looking at space not just as a
strategic asset but also as sort of a
source of future profitability
if you look at the likes of what elon
musk are doing they're trying to
colonize other planets and any country
any company any individual that does it
first will have a big first mover
advantage
i think in order to make space
exploration in the coming of century
be more humanistic and inclusive
geographically speaking racially
ethnically is going to be a huge
challenge because a lot of the money
rests in a certain part of the world
it would end up being an expedition of
sorts
where you would only have the wealthy
participate leaving behind a large
section of the earth it's not going to
look very pretty
in 1990 asian nations represented only 9
of global space spending
now it's 19
and rising india is determined to be a
leader not a follower in the new space
race
[Music]
you